hello everyone my name is Seth manikin a
associate professor in comparative Media
Studies and writing here at MIT and the
director of the communications forum I'm
thrilled that you're all here for this
tonight this is a forum that I feel
really strongly about and I'm very glad
that we're getting to hold it one
correction to your programs
Nadeem unfortunately was booked here and
at someplace else simultaneously his
assistant apparently had two events and
decided instead of working out that
conflict he would just marry them and
make them one event so he texted us a
little while ago saying why aren't any
of you at Suffolk so he will not be here
but he Shaam will be here in his place
and so without further ado let me
introduce our panelists down on the end
Abubakar Abid is an engineering master's
student at MIT and a member of the
Muslim Students Association Muslim
Student Association he is currently
working on building wireless
communications and powering systems for
edible electronics which sounds
delicious and awesome leila Shaklee
holds a master's degree from MIT School
of Architecture and planning and she's
the co-founder of wise systems a
software firm that helps companies make
real-time delivery decisions and the
co-founder of TEDx Baghdad her viral
video sensation which we will definitely
be talking about Muslim hipsters or MIT
stirrers helped launch a national
conversation about how Muslim women are
represented and Hisham bedre is also an
alumni of MIT from the technology and
policy program where he studied new
imaging technologies and their
implication on privacy he was born in
the Sudan and grew up in my hometown in
my hometown of Newton Mass so which
makes me very proud and again thank you
so much for stepping in
at the last second so abu-bakr I thought
I would start with you and one of the
reasons I thought I'd start with you is
because initially the other two
panelists we're gonna have a fairly
public profile but Leila I know you've
dealt with reactions online to your to
your work into you and I want to know
from you if Abu Bakar if over the last
six months or so since the rhetoric
around this presidential campaign has
and a bunch of cases become pretty
hateful if you have noticed any
difference or if you've felt any
different within MIT and then a follow
up to that is has anyone in the MIT
community since you know Donald Trump
said that Islam hates us or since Ted
Cruz said that we should be patrolling
Muslim neighborhoods has anyone within
MIT spoken to you or the Muslim Student
Association about what's going on Thank
You Seth first of all I want to thank
you and the rest of the team for
organizing this and I want to thank
everyone in the audience for coming out
I think this is a very very important
and critical crucial discussion that we
need to be having right now especially
given the kind of political discourse
that we're hearing and this kind of
discourse does have an effect so as such
as you alluded you know a lot of people
on the trail have talked about the fact
that Muslims there's an inherent divide
between Muslims and the rest of American
society and as a consequence I've
actually heard I've heard affects both
happening here at MIT as well as in the
larger American landscape in fact I just
a couple of weeks ago I talked to an MIT
Muslim student who told me that so she's
a she's a Muslim woman she wears the
hijab
she's very visible she's a very visible
Muslim and she told me about a series of
disturbing incidents that she had
experienced
the course of just a couple of months
after these incendiary remarks that
started so one of the things that she
told me was that you know she
experienced just as she was grabbing
lunch at one of the cafes around campus
that one of the server's started
shouting at her and accusing her of all
sorts of terrible things and she on on
campus yeah I'm camp yeah on campus and
this unfortunate you know and another
incident same person as she was boarding
a safe ride ironically a safe ride
she was singled out and asked for
identification whereas all the other
passengers passengers weren't and there
were other incidents as well but the
point is that I think that I think
there's a couple of things one that
these incidents are happening but two
that even me as a Muslim student on
campus I was surprised and shocked to
hear these and I think that points to
the fact that anti-muslim sentiment as
in you know as other examples of bigotry
against minority groups it isn't uniform
it tends to target people who are
they're already the most visible and
potentially the most vulnerable in that
group and I think it's important if we
want to actually get a sense of what's
going on to get as many different to
seek out as many different narratives
and voices and hear from everyone I
think that's the best way of of
understanding what's happening and so
has anyone at MIT within the MIT
community come and spoken to you or said
that they support you or spoken to the
student association yeah so we're
fortunate I think one of the one of the
one of the great things about the MSA
the Muslim Students Association on
campus is that it serves as a vehicle
for interfaith dialogue for building
rapport with other student groups on
campus and so we're fortunate to have
good relationships with with for example
MIT hello we've had joint events with
Cru with the secular student group and
so we have received a strong amount of
solidarity and messages of support from
these other religious groups and we're
very grateful actually to the I know
Robert Fischer actually reached out to
us specifically specifically supporting
what you know as a sign of solidarity
with the Muslim students
campus and we've had similar support
statements of support from other groups
so we're seeing both you know on one
level organized student groups and most
students on campus I think are
supportive of the Muslim MIT Muslim
students here but at the same time we
are seeing these occasional incidents
where Muslim students feel threatened
and feel vulnerable and and it sounds
like you're being very politic but
should I am I correct in assuming that
no one in the administration has reached
out to you oh no I absolutely have
actually oh absolutely
that's just an omission on my point my
point both the president we recently met
with the VP and they've been extremely
extremely supportive okay great
Leila so I mentioned your Muslim
hipsters video I'm gonna assume that not
everyone is familiar with it
so I want you if you could tell us a
little bit about that and then also a
little bit about the reaction to that
yeah definitely it's a pleasure to have
you all here tonight so thank you guys
for coming to make the very clear
distinction I always so our Beck has
done this incredible job in taking
leadership within the Muslim community
and really trying to be a leader and
developing the MSA here I'm totally here
by accident and I'm generally at these
events by accident and I effectively
became a public figure by accident um so
to give you to kind of take ten steps
back I was a teenager when 9/11 happened
and I saw the big shift of the
perception of Muslim women right before
9/11
my mom wore the hijab scarf and my
sister did and it was usually fine you
know people would ask do you get hot and
that you shower in that but that was
effectively the extent of of you know
the funny remarks that we would hear
after 9/11 with this other ization of
Muslims across America that we'd all
experienced alongside I would say a lack
of really differentiating reporting that
indicated kind of that the realities of
of Muslims in America and really the
fact that we are just generally citizens
let's this authorization of us as a
population and I would say that Muslim
women and especially those who choose to
cover we're typically the first victims
of this right alongside random people
seek men aren't even Muslim but you know
people are so upset that they just
unfortunately bared the brunt of the
storm as well I happen to be one of
those Muslim women and I chose to cover
growing up and I still choose to cover
and it really led to old adolescence of
apologetic miss quite frankly you know
that's not like me I'm not like them I
like fashion I like tech I worked at
NASA I'm like some literally tech geek
right and there's a certain point I
would say when I hit 18 19 20 that I
realized that I was just I was over it
the jig was up what was i apologizing
for and why did I spend so much of my
effort in my energy apologizing for
something that I was unrelated for we're
all Americans we should not all be
apologizing for Donald Trump if you
don't support them if you do
nevertheless we shouldn't all be
apologizing for the KKK that happened in
America if you're unrelated and you
don't respect it it's a really
unfortunate set of circumstances and
type of person but they don't represent
us we feel the same way about you know
these these fringe terrorist groups
nevertheless I decided to take action
instead of just the angry and upset and
my passions were tech space and fashion
I was much better at being a creative
than I was creating cool rockets so I
had my friends and I put together a
music video ironically enough to jay-z's
somewhere in America and it was really
an authentic video a really benign video
of a bunch of Muslim American woman
doing what they love to do most
I used to love to skateboard I still
enjoy it I can't say I have the time
also 30 so it's getting to the age where
it's kind of embarrassing
I was I was skateboarding because I'm 43
and I saw my mic so it's technically
correct tonight actually I'm taking my
engagement pictures on a skateboard
so effectively my friends and I put
together this video and we released it
to the Internet not expecting much more
than kind of creating some sense of
awareness to people who weren't Muslim
that was our target audience I happen to
be in Egypt at the time on a UN mission
so it was my nighttime when it was
daytime here and we read all like you
know the statistics on when the best
time to drop a video was and
up in the morning and effectively had
gone literally insanely viral I was like
oh my goodness what do I do now I'm in
Egypt money UN mission like what if they
see me on heels and a skateboard like is
it's gonna affect my job so I rushed
back to the United States that's not
true it just happened to be end of my
mission and I got I got back to the
state side and realized this this whole
incredible dialogue had formed in the
first people to take up the dialogue
were Muslims Muslims saying hey dude
like this doesn't represent me so I'm
not really sure why you put this out
there to which my response was like
that's great that's the point
like we're not one person we're many
different people this is my narrative um
I let that kind of settle out for a few
months and then the response came from
the mainstream and we were picked up
from everybody from GQ to Cosmo to
Glamour I think I'm the first woman in
GQ who isn't in a bikini it's incredible
um to Cosmo to Glamour to Marie Claire
and we just kind of watched I sat back
and watched us this dialogue really
forms on who Muslim women are what
they're supposed to represent who can
speak on their behalf what is a Muslim
woman how loaded is this statement how
loaded is this piece of cloth so as this
incredible incredible dialogue literally
evolved and this video became oddly
iconic I I just took a step back and
soaked it up and then in fact eventually
wrote a piece in the Atlantic just
summarizing at all that if you're
interested in this I suggest you you
read because it really is a very open
view straight from the depths of my
heart to this whole experience I think
I've probably spoken too much but I have
a lot more to say so I'm gonna let you
ask questions everybody keep talking we
can come back a bit but just briefly so
what were so you said some of the
reactions were you know this isn't what
we are as Muslim women what were the
reactions from the mainstream press when
GQ were Marie Claire covered you what
was what were they covering essentially
miss illumine are so cool these women
are so hip muscle moment into fashion
like stylish Muslim woman it was all
about just effectively this particular
medium of creativity we had chosen which
was fashion right and they were just
talking about I mean one of the women
who is in
video is now be first Olympian for Team
USA to wear hijab if to Haj Mohammed she
the fencer she's the fencer so she's in
our video she's incredible my sister is
in it who happens to be the attorney for
the for the Clinton Foundation for
President Clinton who's like a rock star
undercover and pun intended and thanks
for so there was a lot of really clearly
intelligent woman and some women chose
to be artists or you know community
builders but we really focused on the
fashion so people who effectively would
delve deeper be like whoa this keeps
getting cooler like what she's super
smart she's doing such cool things so I
think it was just a lot of awareness to
kind of another angle of Muslim women in
America that quite frankly is it isn't
represented often enough and I'll take
some blame for that because as a Muslim
woman I could probably represent it
myself which is why I did what I did
some so when did you when did your
family move over and did they move
directly from the Sudan to Newton yeah
so actually we moved over when I was
maybe about a year and a half years old
so I don't really remember that very
much at all and maybe 90s yeah we'll go
Andy yeah yeah no earlier than that
earlier than early long yeah but uh yeah
so I guess uh I grew up in Newton
Massachusetts which I would say is
probably predominantly Jewish and so I
had lots of Jewish friends growing up
and went to lots of bar and bar mitzvahs
and it was actually a very good
experience and I would say that uh so I
so I I think part of that you know
experience has shown I mean I think um
so a great book that everyone should
probably read is Cristal knock by
Allegra's l and essentially they're
there talking about the issues of the
Holocaust and more importantly also the
issues of what led up to the Holocaust
and though trust me this is not to
compare directly anything to the
Holocaust but I want to do is you know
they do talk into the concepts of hate
how that really grows up and how that
happens and I could say that you know
beyond just like the physical or even
you know mental stress that Muslims get
placed under there's also the concept
that their struggle Muslim struggle is
very much attempt to be associated with
like the American struggle in general
and I think that unhinge remarks against
Mexicans or women or even
Muslims everything like that you're sort
of shows that you know we're sort of
being placed in the situation where we
are definitely authorizing and the issue
Budin happens when you begin authorizing
is you sort of seeing things like hate
and the others ultimately I think the
antidote to that and I think he likes
all talks about that a lot is and you
really need to start standing up for
other people anytime you say stand
standing up for other people or anytime
something happens you need to understand
that that's you know like it's a direct
attack on me just as much a direct
attack on other people as soon as we see
like underrepresented voices or
minorities in check like that I think
you're gonna see you know essentially
other dire consequences happening
unfortunately I think that these
environments essentially lead to
situations wherein it only takes a small
lapse of judgement and it's not
necessarily gonna be you or me or
anybody we know but I mean ultimately
like you could be in a situation where
the cards don't go in your favor and
this environment essentially pulls out
the entire safety net meaning what what
a small lapse of judgment meaning why so
for example I think um I mean everyone
you know undergoes feelings of panic the
course there was a story of recently
there was a Muslim woman on a train who
was I think literally just going to work
I don't remember the exact details of
this story but she was really going to
work and on the train she was approached
by many different passengers asking if
what she was carrying was a bomb or not
and that's situation that could
immediately you know escalate into
something which nobody involved would
ever want it's so a little bit of you
know like suspicion you know in this
kind of environment can easily escalate
to something which could be extremely
dire so the point is we build these
safety nets to not just protect
ourselves but to protect those around us
and I think that you know as soon as we
see kind of hate speech flying we have
to realize that you know it's going to
affect everyone anyone is an
underrepresented minority anyone who has
a voice that's dimming from other people
and in the end that's what a democracy
is about
we all have voices which are slightly
different we need the room to be
controversial we need the room to also
be different and without that kind of
safety net we're gonna essentially see
bad stuff happening and so that's
interesting and it reminds me of I think
in 2014 in Sydney there was after a
gunman held people hostage in a cafe
there was a was it I'll ride with you
the I'll ride with you movement
we're we're Australians were speaking
out and saying publicly if you are
Muslim and are worried about being
harassed I'll walk with you I'll ride
with you
have you seen similar things happening
here
yeah for sure I think yeah I think let
me come up with some specific examples
of a Bucer and are you guys gonna have
to dig but I think yeah but I would say
that you know I think in general the MIT
community has been extremely supportive
I think a lot of the Interfaith
community here at MIT is also extremely
supportive as well as you know like the
higher up you know administration level
but I think in general most MIT students
are just great people to talk to great
people to just have a conversation with
and I think that really becomes a thing
I would say from my experience I have
yet to meet somebody who hate Muslims
I've met I haven't met somebody who
hates Muslims who knows a Muslim I think
that oftentimes that becomes a problem
that essentially we are a minority we
aren't necessarily out there and just
like you were saying very
underrepresented so what happens is you
have lots lots of people who've never
met Muslims before who are only see like
the bad things which are essentially
just serialized in the media and
essentially things become bad no we're
just I can just add on to that I think
one of the one of the issues is while
while Muslims are fairly integrated in
in in in the United States there are
huge pockets of geographical areas where
there aren't many Muslims and in fact
the problem is that you know people
living in those areas don't know many
Muslims and they are because of that
they're resistant to learning about
Muslims and oftentimes you hear stories
for example where most where parents are
concerned about their children learning
about Islam or Muslims Muslims in
schools and so there was this recent
story where for example a school
district in Virginia shut down because
the one of the one of the parents saw
that their children were learning about
Arabic calligraphy in class and so that
kind of resistance to education about
Islam and Muslim I think creates this
unfortunate cycle where you have people
just never learning about Islam and
Muslims and that perpetuates anti-muslim
sentiment and you
see it persist so I think it's very
important to actually end this cycle
before before it becomes you know
continues to be a problem
and so outside you know were within a
community that is not representative of
the United States obviously I'm talking
about MIT in some ways probably in a lot
of ways but so outside of a university
setting are there steps that are being
taken or that should be taken you know
you talked about speaking out against
when you see hate and if you look at
again you know what Ted Cruz has been
saying what Donald Trump has been saying
what on a local level politicians have
been saying across the country it's
pretty scary stuff and in my perception
at least from outside of the Muslim
community is that it has not been met
with as robust a reaction against that
as you might see yeah I mean are you
talking about from outside of the Muslim
community r with him from outside the
Muslim community yeah from outside of
the Muslim community absolutely which I
mean it's a tough issue right because
within the Muslim community you hear
this criticism sometimes from the
outside saying well if you're not one of
them why don't you stand up against it
and first of all many Muslims you're not
one of them
meaning a terrorist effectively why
don't you stand up against it and the
truth is if you check any of our
Twitter's after any attack it's always a
clear like you know hearts out to the
victims etcetera etc but there's a real
reality to it the reality is that
ultimately when people when especially a
whole population of people spend their
time being defensive they're not doing
something else so when I'm not being
defensive about Who I am
I'm usually building something in the at
the moment building a company right to
effectively be a good daughter a good
sister I'm really contributing to
something greater and I think that that
is really one of the biggest challenges
of people our age who happens to be
Muslim is there's so much energy that as
a result of this lack of education is
being
wasted on being defensive and being
apologetic one effectively the end of
the day I'm unapologetically American
and there's really nothing nothing to
apologize about
and and and you you you raised you know
the the fact that oftentimes after a
terrorist attack or even not after a
terrorist attack you'll have people
saying well why isn't the Muslim
community speaking out about this do you
think that that's a situation where when
Muslims do speak out it's not getting
covered or that people aren't speaking
out within the community for fear of
trying to attention themself or
something no I think I think every but
anybody who's afraid is gone by now
in other words after their September
11th there was awful events like you
know Belgium there was San Bernardino if
you're scared of being a Muslim movement
you've cut you're out like you're not
you're not left you've left the
affiliation the Association you've
Americanized yourself you've assimilated
in other ways and you're not probably
you've left the US but you're not
partaking with that identity we all have
friends like that and that's fine who
just effectively don't want to deal with
the criticism and have assimilated in
ways that they've effectively absolved
your left they're their original
identities and that's not my choice to
make right so a lot of the Muslims that
you see now that are choosing to look in
the Muslim have made a very conscious
decision to do what we're doing right
because there's been many like
opportunities to walk out on the
identity as a whole I would say for
Muslims my age it has to be a choice
because you are constantly dealing with
so much backlash on an everyday level
like to be quite honest I was at the
airport yesterday I didn't even think
twice I just put a hood on I'm like I'm
not gonna wear my hijab I don't wanna
put up with this right you know like I
need to get to Boston I don't wanna be
randomly selected again so I think that
especially as a woman because that's
what I can
especially speak for it's a really
conscious decision to be and look like a
Muslim woman today in America you shum
do you find that that's true that that
among your peers you know I guess in
contrast I don't necessarily identify
myself as being religiously Jewish but
identify is being culturally Jewish and
it sounds like what you're saying is
that
people who might identify as culturally
Muslim but not necessarily religious are
essentially just not even are saying
well I'm not even gonna identify myself
as cultural culturally Muslim is that so
are you saying that well I think among
many Muslim communities I think you're
gonna find that you know like no matter
how far away people I guess are from the
mosque or where they live or you know
like that there is you know like this
very very strong identity like Muslim
identity is still like you know strong
part of their lives and I say that
comparatively because you know I have
lots of friends who are you know not
necessarily religious or anything like
that I could say that you know
comparatively like you know like Muslim
identity is something that you know
still plays a part even if like you know
you haven't been you know to the mosque
ever in your life you know you barely
know very much about the religion
anything like that but you're still like
you still have like this feeling and
that's all gonna speak for everyone but
I can say that on the whole if we're
like took like the mean compared to
people who are you know not necessarily
Muslim I think it's you know yeah
there's there's something that people so
essentially do like about this thing so
but I would say this do the other thing
I mean do like like like they still are
able to like you know hold on side and
maybe it's because we can't necessarily
even you know like escape it you know
like there are so many situations where
that you know like the day will come up
you brought up an extremely good point
being Muslim when were in America you
like you're essentially bad identities
on the forefront all the time but I
think that to your earlier point do
people feel you know like they need to
be apologetic ready to date that I think
that regardless I think when people get
hurt I think Muslims definitely feel
that hurt we're just as American as
everybody else and if you were even to
add a layer of extraction to that I
think you see that you know overseas
terrorists are killing more Muslims than
anybody so it's you know like I and not
only that you know like when a terrorist
attack happens your first reaction is oh
my god this is absolutely terrible
second reaction is oh my god this is
about to be even more terrible because
there's gonna be you know a backlash
that goes apart that but I think that's
just I think you know like that's but I
would say there's definitely three
examples I can think of a top of my head
that of people who are not necessarily
Muslim but who have done great ways of
essentially making it easier for Muslims
so this goes way back but I think at the
top level I think : Powell when Brock
running for president essentially
there's a lot of talk about oh my god
Barack Obama's a Muslim oh my god he's a
Muslim I think Colin Powell came out
exactly um but I think all those
responses still really important he said
you know he is a not a Muslim and B even
if he was it shouldn't matter and I
think you know being of the Bush
administration standing out like that it
showed that you know I think um he was
one not to be bullied around
although the Bush administration in
general you know the the at least right
after 9/11 george w bush's rhetoric was
certainly very embracing of american
muslims
that's my memory yeah there's always a
filter of media i think that that goes
and i think that if you're a look at
like in practice a lot of the policies
that happen we're sure that the exact
opposite happens right so i think uh but
and the second exam owner bring up um is
actually at MIT and i'm sorry to call
you out for this but dean Randolph i
think i was after the essentially uh
this i think it was the San Bernardino
shootings we were gonna have Muslim
prayer on Fridays and then he went ahead
and he called a police officer to just
be outside the the mosque you know like
when that happened so that was just
really great and that was him you know
standing up and saying you know like I
want to ensure the safety of you know
MIT Muslims I want to ensure the safety
of people who are faces calling someone
out if you're complimenting them well I
think I think you know I think there's a
pretty humble people here and the last
example I really got to say this um so I
work in this electronics store and there
was somebody there and they don't know
I'm Muslim at all and I was walking by
two co-workers talking and I'm sorry to
bring racism but they were they were
they were both white it's all good they
were the really cool people and
essentially some of my best friends are
white I know it's crazy so and so and
then I just overheard the conversation
and then I think one guy was saying to
the other guy who's just like you know
just explaining that you know like you
know there's over a billion Muslims on
this planet you know like in like you're
saying Isis is like fifty thousand
people like that represents poisoners or
one percent and that if the you know if
there was a significant part of them
that were dangerous none of us would
even exist and then he kept going and
talking about like you know like I like
all like the actual just literal facts
of the situation I suggest people to
check out savages
it's a song in the Pocahontas movie oh
man I think it can it can look at a can
really describe you know a lot of the
things that are going on they today
essentially sides are becoming polarized
and it's really over nothing and
essentially when you start down and look
at the facts there's nothing but really
good opportunities I think hey just like
this really weird thing that like you're
saying it's like this just there's that
there's a nonlinear effect that occurs
when you start dealing with hate but so
you know we're talking about examples of
people outside the Muslim community
standing up and and making both saying
that this is wrong and making Muslims
feel welcomed and accepted the fact that
the examples that we come up with are
Colin Powell from eight years ago a Dean
at MIT two random white dudes and a
Disney movie doesn't make me feel like
there is a lot going on in our in our
culture as a whole is that and and
anyone can jump in that's really
interesting no go for it so there's one
example I can think of I would say on
the culture as a whole
probably not you're correct but it's
it's it's a challenging topic right
because I mean what are you gonna do is
somebody who's not Muslim on supporting
Muslims hold a sign up and walk around
and be like I support Muslims I mean
they're the real right thing to do is to
kind of have more events like this and
create more use whatever kind of
leverage you have and especially outlets
to different newest news channels and
media outlets to kind of spread a
different alternative narrative because
there's effectively one very overbearing
narrative out there right now I would
say in the last three four years the
narrative has become a bit more diverse
and you see a lot a lot different angles
kind of coming out about about Muslims
particularly in America but yeah going
no no but to go back to your initial
question my mom is like this incredible
rock star she was at one point in her
life an orthodontist quit that to open a
Muslim school pre-k through 12th the
city of knowledge in Pomona California
best place on earth WASC accredited
and she after 9/11 when I was in middle
school I think I remember that morning
or the next morning when schools back
back in place um
local Jews and Christians from the local
Interfaith community literally stood by
the gate every day before school and
after school so students would come and
go and feel comfortable and they did
that for weeks and weeks it was
incredible and my mom called me after
the San Bernardino attacks happened
because San Bernardino's about 40 minute
40 miles away from Pomona and the the
same community had done the exact same
thing and it was the most simple thing I
mean 15 minutes in the morning and 15
minutes in the afternoon
right but it truly like resonated with
her
so you'll see random effects like this
particularly in focused communities like
interfaith communities etc but I think
the issue is much much larger than kind
of random acts of kindness at this point
it's widespread acts of information that
really might mitigate right right
Abubakar we were talking earlier and I
know you haven't read it yet but about
an a fascinating article in BuzzFeed
about the experience of Muslims living
in Tennessee and how radically that is
shifted from feeling incredibly
integrated and actually one of the
reasons that some of the Muslims in
recorded in the piece said they felt so
integrated was because they could relate
and identify very clearly with the
evangelical population around them that
that was a population that took faith as
seriously as they were taking it and
there was sort of a Brotherhood there
the article ultimately is about now how
that feeling of acceptance has sort of
disappeared you as your family still in
Arkansas so my family is now in
Fayetteville Arkansas and so what is
their experience been
not just now but over the past you know
16 17 years yeah this is a good question
and I think we talked about earlier how
you know maybe some Muslims are choosing
to identify or become less visibly
Muslim so I think what I what I see more
happening more than that is people
choosing to become less politically
outspoken less less along the lines of
you know calling out government
surveillance programs of Muslims any any
way that they can choose to draw
attention less attention to themselves I
hear this all the time for example from
my parents but tell me don't do anything
political that's like the number one
piece of advice I get from that just
don't do anything political everything
else is fine and I you know even for
example III a couple years ago I served
as a president of the MIT Muslim
Students Association and even that was -
a lot of people a lot of my relatives
about um you know my parents said you
know are you sure are you really sure
you want to draw that kind of attention
to yourself and I think that is the real
toll that a lot of Muslims are taking is
that they are way more hesitant to call
out for example aggressive foreign
policy domestic surveillance programs
even some of the extreme rhetoric that
you're hearing that's continuing because
a lot of Muslims just don't want to
challenge that because you know for
example you have candidates like Ted
Cruz and Donald Trump calling out let's
let's patrol Muslim neighborhoods now
you can't really identify Muslim
neighborhood but you can't identify
Muslim with speaking
you know outspoken about these kind of
issues so a lot of people are just
taking a step back and saying okay
there's a risk involved I don't want to
be part of it and that's again you know
this is another vicious cycle that
allows these politics you know these
these distort discourse to go
unchallenged and these policies to
persist so I think that's the real real
real toll of these kind of these kind of
discussions well and and we can refer to
the ghost of Nadeem now one of the one
of the things you know he's I think the
first Muslim elected official in
Massachusetts he's also been very active
he started mass Muslims
and organizing the Muslim community
especially the younger Muslim community
politically is there the type of
generational divide that is discussed
where maybe people in your parents
generation would prefer not to get
involved politically where people in in
in our or a final qualify your
generation are at least looking for how
to how to navigate that how to both
speak out about what they believe in and
also exist safely and company within the
society and anyone can jump in on this
is there generational divide yeah I
certainly see a generational divide part
it's either generational or it could be
you know cultural people who have come
to the United States as first generation
immigrants they're much less likely to
see the value of implementing policy
changes so as long as they live their
lives comfortably they're kind of okay
with that but people who are here in the
second generation feel a lot more
invested I think in the political
process and absolutely so like mass
Muslims is doing a great job going to
Capitol Hill presenting a list of
legislative demands to the Capitol and I
think that's going to be key and kind of
getting some of these changes over
overturned because we don't talk about
this but a lot of the rhetoric that you
see on the campaign trail
it doesn't just exist as rhetoric like a
lot of those policies have already been
implemented domestic surveillance not
too different than patrolling
neighborhoods or the equivalent and you
know in a certain immigration policy is
certain foreign policy foreign policies
all of those are already in place and I
think that you know we have to we have
to take the step to start challenging
that well and you say certain aggressive
foreign policies and that's one to me
that's one of the most fascinating areas
because certainly in the population in
general there are a lot of people who
disagree with aspects of American
foreign policy over the past decade but
for Muslims to speak out about that
publicly see
to carry a sort of unique it seems to be
fraught in a different way
at least from from someone looking at it
from the outside is that true I
definitely you people are going to call
into question your identity if you how
American you are right I think as your
as you start challenging foreign policy
like oh you care more about these people
than you care about your own people or
things like that
but I don't think people should be all
that worried about that I think um
there's a lot of foreign policy points
people make which I think are very much
universal I think blowback is a terrible
thing and I think that uh I think you'll
see amongst many Muslims you know like
they share the same kind of opinions
with I think look you mentioned most of
the country that you know if you have
bad foreign policy you know it can lead
to bad results in there about most of
the country I feel like that in
Cambridge in terms of the generational
divide I think um well you may see
though is a I don't know if that the
correct term is generational but I would
say that so far from what I've seen
we're just becoming more politicized I
would say that most some populations and
the demons and Councilman is not a great
job essentially instituting a lot of you
know initiatives and finding people who
are very much into politics but I think
that in general in our community we see
a lot of people who are not necessarily
in the political end of the spectrum or
even in the arts end of the spectrum you
may see a lot of people in science and
engineering which I mean of course for
there's like like at least 50% of our
population is immigrants or like came
from your backgrounds so you can see
that you know typically that is
something you would expect from an
immigrant population focusing on tech
focusing on things that you know will
immediately lead to you know like
grounding in this country but I think
that in general
politicization of you know like just be
able to stand up taking take
participating and like civics and the
like is really the exit for Muslims from
like this cycle or at least that's what
a lot of people strategize ask and I
think that a you're gonna see more and
more of that I mean a good example to
prove that is um there's more and more I
think there's scholarships
you know pointed towards Muslims given
from Muslims to Muslims you know for to
for Muslims to go into things like media
and arts and
what even for Muslims to Muslims you
mean essentially fun being given by
Muslims for Muslims you know essentially
internal scholarships things like that
right essentially to go into things like
media into politics and I think that's a
little bit unheard of because I mean as
I've run high school programs before
it's you know very difficult or I think
anybody who's tried to get a fellowship
in anything liberal arts related it's
really hard you know yeah but it's
interesting in this community that's
essentially encouraged so I think that
you will see more relatives with
politicization politicization more
people involved in civics and that's
gonna be very interesting to see I think
with our generation certainly is more
politicized I wouldn't tell you that
it's per se a generational difference
it's generational for sure but I
wouldn't say it's because we tend to be
more interested in politics as a whole I
think we have to be I think that around
particularly right now it's evident that
we're a medium for votes for particular
candidates in a very effective medium
for votes so there are some people who
are really interested by politics and
want to know everything and want to be
involved and there's the rest of us that
really should know a thing or two
because we're really really being you
know highlighted in many many many times
and points at this particular for
example presidential race and at other
points so you kind of have to be fairly
political as a young Muslim who chooses
to practice and be very like you know
outwardly Muslim because as I said we're
a medium and in this particular race is
that do you two both agree with that
that to be a religious Muslim at this
moment in history in the u.s. is
inherently a political act as well as a
religious act yeah I mean I'd say for
the a lot of people feel like if we're
gonna survive as a community and be able
to practice effectively we need to
become political yet you know I I would
say there are people though that you
know choose to distance themselves for
the political process for you know
survival of the self they don't want to
draw attention to themselves you know I
because I'm in the Muslim community you
hear stories all the time about for
example the New York Police Department
sending undercover agents that pretend
to for example convert and become
Muslims and then they join the MSAs they
join the Muslim student associations and
then they just you know they embed
themselves undercover
and what that does is I've had
conversations with so many students when
I encourage them to Muslim students when
I encourage them to come to MSA events
and they'll say uh you know I don't know
I don't want to be too political that's
their answer political not religious
because they're they're torn right so
they want to practice their identity but
they just feel so much safer practicing
it alone so I think you know for the
long-term survival of the Muslim
Students Association yes absolutely we
need to get engaged with the political
process so what does it say I mean one
of the interesting reactions to the
political rhetoric that's occurred over
the last couple months was actually from
the Commissioner of the NYPD who I
thought spoke out he was among the most
forceful people who spoke to speak out
right off the bat insane how on American
Ted Cruz's comments were and talking
about all the Muslim officers the fact
that you have that coming from an
organization that has been really
heavily criticized for its surveillance
tactics what is that what does that say
Linda's or something a great job a great
job so she's also an activist in the
area and I think I'm really glad that he
actually came out and did you know make
those comments cuz I mean I think it uh
and I think what was awesome with seeing
those comments some places also like Fox
Fox News and you know broadcasts that
you know aren't necessarily usually
great this kind of information so I
think that's absolutely awesome I think
that one of the may be a silver lining
in this presidential campaign has is
that the for example issues like the
surveillance of Muslims has become
politicized in the sense that you know
one party is now becoming sort of
becoming associated with it sir perhaps
members of the other party are kind of
distancing themselves say oh this is
actually not us even though maybe five
years ago everyone would have been kind
of fine with it it was kind of low-key
and it was happening but now people are
forced to confront it as a political
issue
so you think five because because
certainly both Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders have spoken out very
strongly you think five years ago before
it had become the political issue it it
is today that that was not the case or
that one I think I think you only need
to look at the the change in stance of
the
commissioner himself I don't know if it
was the same same police commissioner
but I'm imagining there was more
alignment in policy than there is now so
I think I think things are changing to
that extent but then the problem with it
becoming a political issue is then half
the country is now in favor for it and
half of it is against it
I mean we ideally want to get to the
point where everyone feels it and what
in favor or against what programs like
keeping a closer tab on Muslims almost
in patrolling that kind of thing the
details of that program it was pretty oh
yeah absolutely yeah yeah essentially
they they had they'd essentially been
monitoring or surveilling or had
informants
in essentially msas and other
essentially Muslim organizations and
mosques which here's the critical point
even beyond New York into other states
such as New Jersey and the rest of New
England so it was a very large and
extensive program and the thing is
that's you know these are the programs
we learned about now and it's
essentially the questions are what are
the kind of things that were happening
even before new thoughts about that yeah
so I was the one who kind of mentioned
that some Muslims don't choose to be
political they just become politicized
I'm one of those actually I'm so deeply
engaged in my work that I generally have
no idea what's going on right so I don't
think on the right I don't think I'm
very person to ask for it I haven't even
read enough I did listen to an
incredible NPR story on it that I
recommend for everybody who knows but
very little on the topic but I don't
think I know enough to comment yeah
there's also there's also a documentary
called terror that's terror yeah I think
that's coming out of Netflix so very
interesting is about terror
yeah just called yester tea and then in
parentheses err no but the idea behind
that documentary is it's actually very
intriguing they follow a a live FBI
entrapment scheme as it's happening
they're able to get some reporters and
apparently the FBI doesn't even know
about it but no but I think that's
really the scary part because it's to
the point where so this whole idea of
entrapment where FBI agents are sent to
convince potential people to commit
crimes and then or you know get rewarded
essentially for catching them in the act
of doing so and then
and in some cases pressure those people
to then become informants exactly
exactly yeah
wait which I guess gets me or gets us to
one last issue I wanted to talk about
before we opened it up Jessica Stern is
a political scientist at BU and possibly
also at Harvard and she has talked about
how one of the things Isis is attempting
to do is essentially make it impossible
for there to be moderate Muslims by
generating so much hate against Muslims
that Muslims sort of feel like
radicalization is their only choice at
that at that point and she has talked
about how that has the potential and has
been much more successful in Europe
where the Muslim community is much less
integrated when there are things going
on like the FBI programs like the NYPD
surveillance programs like homeland
security surveillance programs what are
the risks of do those risk what types of
reactions do those risk causing
essentially what type of reactions to do
that would the the the you know the the
the surveillance program you know if you
are worshipping at a mosque that you
find out has not only been under
surveillance but had had had plants
there or if you're someone who is
entrapped and then pressured to become
an informant during situation like that
what what types of reactions does does
that risk causing I think the big worry
or the big concern is that Muslims will
become will go kind of into hiding and
not even go to the mosques and
institutions so we know there's been
many studies that show that if a Muslim
is going to the mosque is active in
their civic organizations they are much
much less likely to even think about
radicalization right that's that's been
consistently shown and so if you scare
people if you have Pro you know if
people are protesting the buildings of
mosques if people are thinking that oh
my my mosque might be bugged I think
then there might be a concern that that
you know that people are going to get
their information from the internet
rather than from institutions that are
actually providing legitimate Islamic
information and so I think the concern
isn't some I know I think has less to do
with homogenius like you know the the
department with some pockets that are in
Europe or that may not be here but I
think the concern should be making sure
that Muslims feel comfortable going to
mosques and participating on a civic
basis and Leila one last question before
I open it up so when you became a sort
of public figure and were kind of held
up as a public example of what it meant
to be a Muslim woman were there did you
receive any threats did being out in
public
to that extent caused you to ever feel
less safe than you had previously I mean
on the internet there was a lot of
threats in real life people were just
like that's cool you're really cool but
like on the Internet certainly that's
where all the crazies come out right um
and threats are along what lines you
things from like you know the the kind
of flip side of the equation that really
is a song phobic along the lines of like
you know
you XYZ Muslim you're all the same like
don't try to put some cold pants on it
and make it look like it's not
threatening and then you know really
conservative Muslim sort of like you're
not even Muslim just like that you know
what are you doing so I think that's
just the reality of life it didn't
really but those aren't threats as much
as that's just nasty it's it's yeah
threats isn't like feeling I wasn't safe
yeah threats is is even you know comment
saying like someone should do something
to you or no I mean I didn't really read
too much of the comments section let's
see that's that's so good yeah it's
definitely something I learned quick um
so now I can't say it I felt any threats
um no III can't say that was the case
but I was really taken aback by the
extent and growth of the conversation
itself because it really proves that
there's this incredible vacuum over the
topic right we're all so deeply kind of
involved in this conversation about the
fact that we're not terrorists and I
can't even answer your question about
homegrown terrorism because I have no
points of reference I'm scraping my
brain trying like well maybe I don't
know I've never met a homegrown
terrorist right I know like every Muslim
in America um you have to write
literally literally so I think I think
there's a really real reality that there
is a huge vacuum of information and of
kind of I guess role models or public
figures etc which is why I've kind of
taken the role even though I kind of
have no interest in it in the sense that
I really spend a lot of time working
right so you know but at the same time
we'll make two hours on a night like
tonight to come out and talk about the
issue because it's really important so I
not just on a night like tonight
you're leaving around for your wedding
yeah yeah so I told that looks like I'm
coming but I gotta leave real soon
because I'm impact anything so I think
it's a critical topic I think it's
really important that everybody's here
tonight regardless of where you stand on
the spectrum because you need to not
only learn but you need to teach others
and if you're of some other minority
community whether you're transgendered
or whether you're some other minority
religious community you're probably
feeling a lot of the same feelings and
you're probably being target
similar ways they might have real
reactions whether it's being treated
poorly or not getting the job you want
so the next time that you feel a little
funny towards somebody you should have
some empathy and teach somebody else
about your own circumstances and you
know spread the love all right with that
why don't we open it up to audience
questions we have two microphones this
is being recorded so when you ask
question please identify yourself just
so we know who you are
hi my name is Tish abusive thank you so
much for that wonderful commentary from
all three of you might you had a
question before leaving so we talked
about how you know is our existence as
Muslims is it a political existence and
how does politics politics play a role
in our lives and you know I was just
thinking would you you comment on sort
of these systems that we have to live in
these systems that are oppressive and in
in oppressive not only to us as Muslims
but as our identities I think everyone
on the stage has a complex multi-layered
identity you know who Shambhu Sudanese
who's Arab who's black who's also Muslim
Lalo's eran an American but a woman an
American and and how do you there all
those things and how do you kind of talk
about isn't our existence in itself
political and the actions we do aren't
they political in themselves especially
when we're coming from these
marginalized spaces and I just wanted to
hear your comments on that when you say
systems that are oppressive can you
explain that sure yeah I'm have to
explain that so I mean in terms of
policies that are passed out on local
and regional on a national level at
press in communities that were our
parents are from abroad from communities
that we live in here from housing and
discrimination policies and housing and
education and health care I'm personally
in the medical profession and just just
the the the things we choose to do
whether we want to cover or practice our
faith or fast in the hospital and how
that affects how we are perceived in
professional personal spaces and I think
that those systems kind of place a
weight on our on our choices to practice
or to affiliate with a certain religion
or ethnic group or have a certain color
of skin that's what I'm talking
any replies thoughts no I think it very
much echoes a lot of the sentiments that
we're talking about like I think his
shams comments came a lot from what he
experiences and I think effectively he's
echoing the sentiment that as a young
Sudanese Muslim American he you know
very clearly feels like there's some
sort of politicization of his identity
whether he likes it or not but my name
is Omer first of all thank you for this
enlightening panel so as we're all I
guess for the most part MIT alum who are
living in a progressive city like
Cambridge so I was wondering if we as
Muslims run the risk of looking at the
glass as half-empty
rather than half-full so for example
here at MIT president rife you know has
been very vocal in defending Muslim
students likewise with councillor
Madison there was a hit piece that was
run in Breitbart news but right after
that his colleagues Dean and is
unanimously voted in her aid
they basically voted to condemn that
piece and as you know unanimously passed
and this is after a very contentious
election where they're not so kind words
shared between him and his colleagues so
I my question is do you risk downplaying
you know all our allies by emphasizing
the negative aspects like we talked
about Trump but we're not talking about
senator Sanders and his campaign and his
message of positivity and his life
attempts to reach out to Muslims to like
be very vocal and supporting Muslims so
could he please comment on that I mean
I'm I should add add the caveat that I
am speaking as a male who's not visibly
with Muslim who is living in a very
progressive society with someone who's
gotten opportunities more than like 99%
of this country's so I would have to say
that okay first of all why you're so on
I got to say that um that was a really
awesome question I'm really glad that
you decided to go against the grain and
you know like I guess the I guess the
crazy liberal media grain and you know
like um bringing up this point and I
think that uh I would
as a quick response I would say that we
should do as much as we can to identify
our allies because there's many of them
and they stand up for us all the time
even in ways that we don't even ever see
and I think you bring a great point on
that at the same time I think that part
of and I think that as much as you know
like if you're if you're a minority you
know it's not that that you have to have
allies and you're done know if you're a
minority you have to have allies you
need to be allies for other people and
everything like that and I think that we
need to be as much allies to other
peoples we can be and I think that's
part of being an ally is also
understanding that as you get up to
stand up you there's also you know
you're throwing away the level of
recognition that you're doing it for I
mean that's really what's also about
being an ally I think you can have both
you can have people both you know
complimenting our allies everything like
that
and at the same time you know like
allies not necessarily you know asking
for recognition I think that uh that
being said the positivity point only
carries so far I would say that
highlighting people who we think are
awesome and great and doing you know
like really good stuff it's very
important but it doesn't carry as far as
you know like bringing up the specific
points and the specific dangers that
people face every day and I think that
one thing that you could explain is like
for example like there's there's a
there's currently a cemetery being you
know built a Muslim cemetery cemetery in
Massachusetts now and ours Oh
so I think um and and I've been in
Milwaukee where they try to build a
mosque too and I've been to the public
hearings and it is really really hard
the Massachusetts issue there's a huge
debate right about whether it's gonna be
allowed and right right right and it's
actually like and some of the comments
were you know like you know like what
are they gonna do they're gonna build a
cemetery here and then they're gonna
build a mosque in like as in like what's
worse than a dead foot so we got a live
one in like but um but I think you know
highlighting those things but you know
comparing that to say like you know like
Roxbury cambered and say well look
Roxbury did this and they accepted the
Moscone it did well for them or
Cambridge did this and they accepted the
Moscone it's good for them I think there
is a very strong media
to be said for focusing on places like
this where things are not getting done
then saying you know like rocks great
did a great job and that part of the
story will come in later on I promised
you when they cut the ribbon you know
when it opens up places like Roxbury
places like you know like Cambridge and
other places will be celebrated but I
think highlighting the danger is very
important yeah just to add to that I
think you know as I think I'm sure you
mentioned in your question and you
recognize there are a there's a spectrum
of vulnerability in many parts of the
country in different occupations there
are Muslims who are more vulnerable and
it's important to highlight their
opportunities and again I just want to
echo the point of finding allies that's
really important not only for the
ethical and the moral and the religious
mandate to stand up for what they're
going through but also I think very
practically speaking a lot of the media
as a certainly social media that we
experience there are these you know
there are these echo chambers there are
these different lanes that people get
their information from people that have
very similar viewpoints so I think from
a very practical reason it's very
important to identify key people in
different in who can serve as different
allies and get the word out and I think
that's really the most important
expression of solidarity that as a
non-muslim one can make towards the
Muslim community and vice versa is
really sharing us all just sharing our
stories and our mutual understanding of
of mutual cooperation and kind of change
challenging the narratives and
challenging power structures that exist
other questions
hey I'm blacker as a guy huh
it's funny to see on the panel yeah I
know you outside but I was just really
struck by the the first example you gave
of a friend of yours at MIT who had the
server in the dining hall yell at her
and I guess partly what I feel is like
you know I wish if things like this are
happening I wish I knew more about that
I mean maybe it's like one-of-a-kind and
that that's good to know but you know
things like this happened I'd like to
know more about it and so what I sort of
wonder is is there a way that you know
we can we can make make people more
aware that things like this happen
cuz like abstractly okay by reading the
news I know okay there's probably some
level of a there's a level of
Islamaphobia in America but to actually
hear a concrete example and like to
think I could be you know I could be at
an MIT dining hall and imagine if I were
at an MIT dining hall and you know one
of the servers started yelling at me
because of my ethnicity or my religion
and then to think that that happens so I
think would be a good idea if there's
some way to publicize the fact that
something like this happened and you
know that's a good point as I mentioned
I was surprised to hear that so yeah so
you know absolutely and and I think you
know perhaps like anonymous services
like MIT confessions for example could
be a good outlet or perhaps there could
be an outlet that you know different
minority groups who experience this
could just share internally but
absolutely I think you bring up a good
point perhaps there is there's there's
room for a platform where people can
share stories and bring it up to the
attention of other students faculty
administration absolutely that to know
just this kind idea of a platform or
kind of spreading the word even to add
to your first question in terms of well
why aren't we talking this much about
the good stuff that happens I I do think
that as young Muslims I mean everybody
behind this stage at least I know for a
fact does not talk about terrorism all
day we all have day jobs and they're
very busy and we're all doing really
good at something and they're very
diverse something's right and I think
that we're at at a time
we're more Muslims also need to be
acknowledged for being something aside
from being Muslim
right so you know if you're the best
camera maker or whatever you do in that
lab in all of America
and you've happened to be a Muslim I
feel like we need to be sure to kind of
help each other out with getting that
type of press as well because there's a
degree of humanization that comes with
it and what's lacking on a larger level
is just humanization there's a reason
why some lady thinks it's okay to yell
at a woman in her job for eating because
she's Muslim and clearly she must be an
alien to his earlier point he's never
met anybody who's met a Muslim who hates
Muslims right that's generally how it
works so um yeah I think that in general
it's also a good idea to kind of not
fixate too much on this conversation but
push your colleagues forward regardless
of who they are and kind of get them
that recognition in other spaces and as
Muslim love it so I get so excited when
I see people like it - [ __ ] wear hijab
and they aren't just talking about how
we're peaceful she's like too busy
beating the rest of the world at fencing
right so I think things like that are
really important sure yeah and the kiss
fur I mean I think the proof of the
Islamophobia I mean I think there's many
ways of just I think proving to yourself
there's a very simple test I mean you
can walk outside and put on a hijab for
you know just like try it for a few
hours and see what happens oh did you
report back on your results I think
everyone loved to hear that guy yeah I
mean also be like to hear that result as
well you know like I don't know but I
mean of course to keep yourself out of
danger but what I'm saying is um that
it's uh it's it's there there are ways
of looking at it I think when you when
you take a look at the there's there's
individual aspects of Islamophobia I can
mention many of them they're all very
real and there's the the individual like
say incidents but what I'm trying to say
is you know that what we're looking over
here is like this overarching
essentially you know like um level of
environment of fear which essentially
prevents people from living out their
regular daily daily lives as Americans
I'm gonna be very clear being part of
America means that someday you can hope
to run for president and a great example
no I mean that's a thing and if you have
you know people like say like Ben Carson
I was so disappointed I'm sorry it
doesn't matter what Trump says I mean
he's Trump right but when you have other
people
like who run in line and essentially say
you know like I would you know I
wouldn't be happy with you know like a
Muslim president or something like that
things like this you essentially see
that there's this aspect of fear which
sort of hits up to the high level like I
can tolerate Muslims as long as they do
this or I can tolerate listen as long as
they do that but that's really not what
people are asking for this is not really
how you know we should feel comfortable
as being Americans we should be ashamed
of having anything less than accepting
of all Americans I think John Esposito
said a really great thing once and
essentially in a talkies actually said
people being afraid of mosques being
built in this country because they're
afraid of terrorism is like saying
people should be afraid of you know like
a Catholic Church being built because
they're afraid of child abuse and I
think that it's a really great point
like what is it that you know like what
blinders do we have on that if caused us
to you know essentially you know seeing
somebody else who like literally
accessing lives the same there's a poet
named Nabil he's great he has a great
poem about how he's just just like you
and everything is exactly the same but
yet is considered an other and it if it
could happen to Muslims it can happen to
anyone and I think that we just need to
understand like what what is the house
that we're all building together what
does it look like what is it accept and
what is it not and I think we think
about that way thank you yeah like it
seems it part of them what can happen is
that you know maybe if I walked around
looking like very clearly Muslim for a
day nothing would happen but things
happen once in a while and it's those
few incidents that can make that can
create a fear they create fear amongst
people who are afraid of Muslims because
those people might see those incidences
you know for a reason effectively and
well intentioned whereas Muslims see
those things is terrifying like there's
a woman who were her job who was slashed
on a subway in New York within the last
two weeks literally knife to her face
literally like which terrifies me I know
I can probably fight back but I think of
my mom and just get very afraid
you shouldn't have to fight back
even kind of like larger trauma right
and the trauma is not only our identity
in the way that we're perceived but I
mean I don't want to take a toll on this
room because I don't think it's a nice
thing to do but I bet if I asked how
many people in this room had that have
actually been individually affected by
Isis most likely the only the muscles of
raise their hand my best friend's mother
was killed in Kabul literally a by
terrorist attack I was almost killed in
Baghdad that's a whole other story and I
have family member who was killed by
terrorists and it happens to be because
I geographically happened to be closer
in ethnicity to these things and
therefore these things happen and so not
only am I constantly fighting this
identity that's being pushed on me but
I'm actually facing the consequences of
this crazy group of people and I
wouldn't be supplied it surprised if
there were more Muslims that were
affected I can actually probably
guarantee there are more Muslims that
are affected by this than anybody else
and so there really needs to be some
sort of change in this larger narrative
other questions they can also be hard
questions is there anything else any of
you want to add or that you feel like
we've not touched on or do you feel like
we have touched on everything in the
history of the universe in the past in
the past 80 minutes I just I just want
to echo Leila's point I think is so
important to humanize the discussion
rather than just focusing on a
particular aspect of Islam and Muslims
just the mere fact that people are able
to buy such simple binaries and just you
know are just just resort to very simple
generalizations the problem is that you
know people are trying to instead of
like dealing with this problem of for
example terrorism of bigotry with
precision there's just you know coming
at it axis swinging they're just you
know you know this these these these
solutions these problems require I think
the precision of a scalpel and instead
we're just swinging at it with huge axes
and just like we're not we're not
getting anywhere closer to forming
solutions instead we're just
perpetuating the problem because we we
don't understand really how Muslims in
the u.s. think we don't really think
about how people in other parts of the
world
think so I think it's really really
important to just bring this discussion
down to a human level it's okay to say
no it's totally fine no thank you guys
I'm sure that everybody had other things
to do tonight and it's a really
important conversation and you should
know that not only do I not hope that
you will never be victims of some sort
of other ization in the future but if
you are many Muslims will be by your
side so including us thanks you guys for
all for coming out and I think that
maybe were preaching all to the choir
because everyone's here you know
especially just also people watching at
home I think um probably that's the case
too
so the question I guess you know that
because that comes up is like you know
like how do you reach people who
essentially are not of that mindset and
we're not you know like along those
lines and I think it's really important
to look at the I think statistics of it
I think that I don't know if anyone's
done this plot but if they can you know
try to correlate you know Islamophobia
or even a lot of like this hate speech
to election cycles I think that may
bring up hey we have a joke my house is
like oh it's election season no it's a
song a phobia season that's not just
season no it's but but I think I think
that that is really interesting and I
don't know I maybe we got to ask a
deeper question you know like um you
know why are we why are we doing this
you know to get elected I think that's a
really really hard question I don't
think that's the kind of place we all
want to live in and maybe just a
continue on that point of how do we
reach people who aren't here I mentioned
earlier that oftentimes social media
acts as kind of a social of an echo
chamber where you you are restricted to
people who share your own viewpoints but
I don't think that always has to be the
case just this morning I saw this very
interesting campaign by the country of
Sweden to actually have a they have the
first ever national phone number so it
turns out that if you call this
particular phone number you can google
it you actually reach a random person in
Sweden who signed up for this app
interesting and the reason they bring it
up is because actually has to do with
election cycles socialism all these
questions about socialism are in the air
and Sweden wants to be you know they
want to break down the barriers to
understand you know a lot of people have
questions about this so you you know you
have access to a live so you did good as
we can answer your question and I think
you know the the the important point
that I want to emphasize here is that
they had this nice video which went
viral and through social media they were
able to reach so many people I think
it's important to start looking at that
as a model and and you know building off
of that I think a lot of misunderstood
marginalized communities can follow suit
question in the blue so what the
solution is you have a call we do have a
running program where any Muslim you
approach you can get tea from them it's
it's an obligation you can literally
talk to any Muslim they will give you
tea again mark my word any Muslim any
tea
well thank you all three of you so much
for coming out this was I don't know
whether it was preaching to the choir or
not it was helpful to me because even
though I knew where I stood on the issue
of the rhetoric and Islamophobia I
hadn't spoken with a lot of Muslims
about their day to day experience and I
felt like it was difficult for me to
speak out to the extent that I wanted if
I was speaking from a place of ignorance
so I really appreciate all three of you
coming out and sharing your experiences
I think all of you for being here we do
events like this three times a semester
we have an email signup sheet right over
there and if you sign up we promise not
only do we promise we will not spam you
you might even want us to email you more
because we typically you will only get
about 12 emails a year from us but and
you can find all of our past forums
online for many of them there's audio
and video and write up and this will be
posted likely early next week so thanks
a lot